for nearly a month Sergey scruple and
his daughter Yulia have been unconscious
critically ill by all accounts their
lives in the balance poisoned by a
deadly nerve agent that investigators
even many days later were loath to go
near but now for Yulia at least there
are signs of recovery in a statement
Salisbury hospital said we are pleased
to be able to inform you that Yulia
scruple is improving rapidly and is no
longer in a critical condition
her condition is now stable her father's
condition hadn't changed he was still
critical but stable his home is the
focus of the investigation police
believe the rare nerve agent Navi Chak
was left on his front door the door is
now boarded up it may even have been
removed so too
part of a path this is where police
think Sergei and Yulia were unknowingly
contaminated it's where they found the
chemical poison in its highest
concentration more than the traces found
in places the pair later visited before
they fell ill former chemical weapons
inspector Jerry Smith said the poison
must have been put on the door handle
it's very rare for other people to
actually open your front door so by
putting it on the handle you have a
dermal contact your skin touching where
the material would have may have been
left and that then is immediately onto
onto the your potential victim and the
the process of intoxication will start
from there what form do you think the
poison was in it perhaps more likely
that it's a powder I think if a liquid
then the mrs. crippled when he when he
touched the handle he might have become
aware of it just from the physical
presence of liquid on your hand we know
that the couple were found critically
alert for p.m. how long before that
might the poison have been left there
yeah that's that's a really challenging
question because there's been some talk
that it couldn't have been nerve agent
because nerve agent would have killed
them immediately that simply isn't true
there are so many variables that mean
that we're talking I think hours rather
than any time longer than that
counter-terror specialist chip Chapman
said police activity around the house
suggested the would-be assassins
possible movements those are potential
forensics sites so it's significant that
they're not just at the front of the
house but they're at the rear that has
and indeed down the pathway to the rear
the house and to the right of the house
that to me suggests a potential
infiltration routes near the house
police sealed off a woodland path that
led to a children's play area they were
preparing to search it potentially for
more clues to the attackers approach or
escape route Martin brunt Sky News
Salisbury